nous n'oublierons jamais ce
jour pour
certains ces images les obséderont à
jamais quand j'étais gosse je ris d'être
comme mon père à tous les niveaux et si
ça arrivait
finalement et si je devenais comme lui
sans m'en rendre compte je dois en faire
plus je peux sauver plus de
VI mettezmoi à
l'épreuve rien àir AC les umite il est
gentil on remet à ce soir va sauver le
monde invincible tu es trop gentil avec
moi qui c'est ça mes amis m'appellent le
fa il y a une quantité infinie de
dimensions dans notre univers et je suis
né avec la capacité d'accéder à volonté
à chacune
d'elles arrêtez ce truc tout de suite ou
c'est moi qui vais le faire
et si vous saviez à quel point
j'espérais que vous diriez
ça
tes pouvoirs ne font pas de toi une
héroïne ils te rendent
dangereuse faiteslui payer ce qu'il a
fait à votre monde les 20 dernières
années de ma vie n'était qu'un mensonge
tu veux récupérer ce truc dans ce cas
viens le chercher mauvaise décision trou
du
cul ce que je veux c'est nous
Vanger sale Mor fe arrogant tu es bien
le fils de ton
père peuple de la terre plus vous
résisterez et plus nous serons sans
pitié et ceux qui croient encore pouvoir
nous battre n'oubliez pas je
[Musique]
su